hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's I'm already spitting which is a
little early for me in the game but I'm
going to get through night 3 now my
problem was in the last episode was that
the old Bonnie and chica well I didn't
see chicky yet but Bonnie I didn't know
what to do with them I didn't know how
to deal so now I need to make sure that
I go about the right strategy to be able
to beat them because that is what's
going to kill me I know that's what it's
gonna do so my idea is to kind of go
with the same thing that I was doing
before when I was playing the game
before I didn't necessarily need to
check the side doors because it didn't
matter who was coming after me but maybe
well it's a little early for that don't
you think
oh hi foxy you're here really early my
goodness I really really didn't expect
you to be here so early
oh yeah no no I don't want to get killed
by foxy not this early in the game
alright so long as I go about it nice
and calm
okay well there's a little Balloon Boy
coming my way where is he I need to wind
up the music box
reg Z yeah the egg in the egg you need
come on what you got for me baby what
you got for me
whoa that didn't sound good why is that
such a sound oh hello
who's after me now foxy
boxing their yard okay so I'm not
entirely sure if it matters for the
music box for Fox although I don't know
what I need to do other than that I
really don't think feet mask does
anything from that Oh where's my oh hi
okay that's new
don't wake the baby hello hi Bonnie you
looking good
was that something in Dixon can you go
away please not the mood not in the mood
down the road
she's not going away is he little little
I don't know if spamming my light is bad
for my battery might be bad for Bonnie I
don't know who knows these things I'm
still a little [ __ ]
hey Bonnie Bonnie honey why don't you go
try to find your arm somewhere else and
leave me the hell alone
see getting closer I might losing my
mind or is eating a little closer to me
okay okay okay okay
Hey okay all right I can handle this I
can do this I can do this
okay I can do this
so far so good okay noises noises noises
why noises was this something on the
wall there hi hi hi hey back off back
off back off with your clothes
stranger danger for me okay I think I
need to lie God is here hello you're
adorable I think Oh God Kelly just
everybody calm down
we're still okay I'm not gonna pawn my
radar it's doing that would be a
terrible error I think it's gonna hope I
don't die okay okay I'm just gonna watch
[Music]
okay all right so no matter what if he's
in front of me I'm dead
that's it that's all there is I'm dead
unless I need to put on the mask after
he goes away I don't know I don't know
that's the big problem here I need to
know how to be Bonnie okay need to be
very [ __ ] with my like okay we're
okay
Bonnie doesn't like it in class in the
eyeballs and maybe he's mesmerized by
licking normal bunny would be how about
by Ben so that means I do need to check
everything everything like all the
cameras would be more beneficial for me
to do other than what's going on Mona
bond on bone donor okay I might be bone
might be bone
I might be bond I'm probably going and
he's gonna fit
ah why didn't he get me fan goodput
they're putting on the mask work come on
come on come on come on come on be
faster be faster more accurate well
that's a bad sound but that means that
I'll have time for this
bhakti foxy foxy get ready oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh god oh god where any word she
could go when she could go when she
could go this okay that ain't good
that's exactly the opposite of good but
I got some time if I just go about this
in a calm manner there's only so many
ways so they can kill me so I say just
keep them occupied I should be able to
do this have a baby oh god where's
Barney where's Barney okay
[Music]
it's got a flash it's got a flash some
as fast as I can I can't let you get it
if I die back to you I'm going to
literally blew them up hey know who's
there oh my god what the hell
okay fine by me as much time as possible
oh my god sorry if things are getting a
little [ __ ] right now and it thing's
hard to keep track of god damn I need
this I need this okay I'm throwing on
the mask because that's what the phone
call said they said that foxy wouldn't
be fooled by that the baby would be
woken up it wouldn't matter if I had the
function but it did say that if I did do
the thing with the mask when they
arrived I would be golden and not golden
Freddy but I would be a regular golden
crispy they're gonna cook me up a TV and
serve me to look Kitty's in the
following deck I'm never gonna see
anybody I ever know in love ever again
isn't that good for me just let me live
okay there's still the oh wow God Wow
whoa foxy holy crap I didn't think that
foxy was oh my goodness
and also maybe I need to hold it down
maybe the spazzing isn't exactly what I
want maybe that's not what's good for me
I'm just trying to adjust my strategies
by Oh God okay I just saw foxy like oh
my god
that's not okay bruh that's not okay
what what oh god oh god no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no you're not
supposed to be here I don't like you I
don't like you know okay you're fine
you're fine
is there anybody in the vents but I
should worry about not yet why is there
a guy here already I think I know what I
need to do
God oh no no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh oh oh god I'm dead I'm dead Fox
he's gotta get light I [ __ ] up I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] the pard oh I'm so
bond
oh my god I'm boned oh god I'm boned the
bone come on come on come on come on
[ __ ] she's gonna get right oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] so gonna kill me Oh Julie Fox is
gonna
your stupid minigame WASD take cake to
the children okay
wait the red ones okay nah Freddy this
doesn't seem like a fun yo oh my god Oh
Freddy just a little much - what is that
what is all this so slow who is that
what's up Barney oh the chip the kid
outside is crying oh the kid outside
just died
do that to me put the poop god this game
I'm gonna beat this night I'm not ending
this episode until I beat this goddamn
night okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm giving life I'm giving life so who
is this GoSee guy that's the baby or the
puppet or the Macarena I don't even know
what's going on right now okay so that's
what balloon boy does he stops me from
doing what I need to do great now that
I've died to everybody to move on please
terrible terrible terrible terrible
terrible dare a bullcrap
hi okay okay I'm gonna stay still stay
still stay still you can't do anything
to me
you're the power here okay I know they
were false in there
Oh what am I do okay
I'm supposed to fall again see you again
how many times do let me to die in this
game how many many do they have prepared
for me this is where I ended before
[Applause]
golden Freddy I don't like this oh okay
I'm going back to my original strategy
I'm just going to put the face on as
quickly as possible and hope that they
don't kill me because at this point I
gotta know all their hopes I'm gonna
lose my mind
I'm gonna stress out I'm gonna have a
heart attack on air it's gonna be great
everyone's gonna have so much fun at
Freddy fazbear's pizza of nightmare and
dreams I need to save a bit more power I
ain't gonna cut it
who's clamoring oh God okay
didn't even show that it was there was a
goddamn balloon boy he gone I did I did
we got damnit someone's down the hallway
Foxy's who else would it be okay
okay okay okay okay that is the trick
he's just got to be really quick oh god
that's good I know I know I know mine
whine whine whine whine don't wake the
baby don't wake the baby don't wake the
baby I can't see down the hallway okay
that's okay okay start the cycle over
again cuz I got it I got it I got it
thank good who's the who's neo they're
back again okay so I just gotta be ready
for him when they do pop in a balloon
boys being a bit of a douche and he's
deciding to pop in every once in a while
to check in on me see how things are oh
oh that's fun
wait why is foxy so close foxy looks
closer than he was before I don't like
to look at that don't like don't look at
that I like to look at that see if I
don't know if they're in the fence then
I don't know that they're about to pop
up at me that does give me a little bit
of leeway so so help me so help me here
I don't know yeah come on yeah oh god
I'm running out of power I did too much
too much d'argo fire go Gary go far go
bragh old-fangled there whoa whoa whoa
who's there they're both there that's it
I can't accommodate I can't accommodate
so any moment now chicas gonna pop up in
my face oh that's friendly they're
really getting on my case aren't they
damn it with you and the thing and the
thing that is you get bodies there
took it that's okay you know why cuz I
think I'm almost good okay okay okay
okay okay okay I got the strategy Oh God
let me win
what's so close I'm so close just let me
win let me win
well let me would know okay
let's try out okay okay I'm okay look
okay I don't know what that feels like
so it's an amazing victory but I have
been trying really hard at this Oh
Bonnie
hi okay thank you I'm done now thank you
very much
why is it that the end ever episode if
my heart stops to explode out of my
chest
my heart's I'm actually a Time Lord by
the way so anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the other antedates
of war scare series that I've done in
the past or more five nights praise if
that's what you're into right now and as
always I will see you ignore the crack
in my voice in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]